[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody what is up happy Tuesday
it is Tuesday doesn't feel like it's
used no it's because we had Monday off
yesterday right here in the u.s. hey
everybody how's it going welcome we have
a very special treat for you because we
have gears 5 and we're allowed to show
it we're not the first people ninja beat
us to it yeah couple hours ago he had a
hot exclusive but that mixer exclusive
we're now allowed to play a little bit
of it and we're gonna just get right
into it we're gonna play the first hour
of the campaign we're not gonna play
much more beyond that because a it's
late I don't want to be here all night
be because I don't think I want to spoil
the whole campaign for sure for sure
yeah let's just get ready to it man yeah
absolutely
yeah and then interestingly enough you
actually got to see the game last week
this is you're at a preview event you
did not get to see this opening hour
though no no I did not get to see this
opening hour I did get to see a bit of
the game and we can't really talk much
more than that but yeah you guys should
definitely stay tuned to GameXplain this
week we're gonna have a lot more
coverage coming in a lot more cool
videos breakdowns things like that hot
it can be very excited cool so and this
games out Friday for anyone who either
bought that Ultimate Edition or have
game pass ultimate game pass ultimate
game pass right yeah you can if you sign
up for a to get early access this Friday
and then everyone else can get a chance
for it
what was it the 10th September 10th oh
yes Tuesday Tuesday yeah for everyone
yeah all right so we got act 1 on the
loading screen on a loading screen here
we go
previously I'm Gears I was gonna be
gears for spoilers here they're gonna I
would assume so
we used to protect [ __ ] settlements now
we're about the raid 1 raiding is what
outsiders do you busy look our village
hasn't had power in weeks we need this
fabricator I don't care about the
goddamn fabricator you're taking my
people what happened I remember was ok
yeah I actually never got to play poorly
did one feel free
oh ok I'm the og trilogy so I should
probably play 4 or I guess just watch
this well for the context this is what
they actually something that I did get
to see and they were like oh if you
haven't played for too late and they
just played this I was like alright cool
yeah awesome also for those I know
people are gonna ask it we're talking
right now cuz it's just kind of a recap
for for we will try and be quieter
during cutscenes cuz honestly I want to
watch them too yeah for sure
once it kicks in but right now this is
just more seek your fire
see this weird anyway man there we go
here we go alright box game studios
let's go if sparks go and get it to you
sorry that's terrible
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's like really dramatic it's very
ambient damn
[Music]
[Music]
rayvon since you guys are awesome thank
you
I liked the potential of four
it felt like it was it kind of was
starting to fall a little into the samey
trap by the end was like the whole thing
was like asses swarmed different and
then by the end they're just the locust
again right which was a little like okay
so I get them confused all the time I'm
at this point I'm more like curious
where they're gonna take it seems like
they're thinking I mean they're swapping
protagonists for one thing yeah
definitely it's pretty big it's like all
Kate's story
[Music]
what paint is not ready for this she can
barely keep her eyes open I totally
forgot to record it's fine don't worry
about her
she'll be ready
[Music]
you
[Music]
so do you know what's up with that I do
okay yeah when's the last time you slept
old man Marcus are you still in this
game yeah I got like Kate or cash Kate
thank you okay man Marcus come on it's
Marcus yes Marcus it gets tolerable
all right let's see what we got
it's looks really good on the 1x I was
recently playing the the og gears with
my siblings and those cuts hurt her a
lot greener and a lot more grade that's
for sure
oh yeah he's got all this color
thought they said they were gonna talk
over cutscenes anybody come out too much
not over dialogue at least oh right in
the game plan there we go no more
customs this looks nice yeah you shut up
at the end afford s no this is not an
action apology if I set ass by accident
yeah this looks really smooth all right
so one saying it looks laggy that might
just be your stream or something because
trust me it is buttery smooth on our end
frames there anything so
okay so you did start as a JJ right yeah
all right you can't move that fast in
water like that
JD again with a suit like I kidding me
no way you like so clunky just like kind
of mob and they are trying to get
through the water yeah it's not letting
me sprint just stream freezing uh try
try rebooting if the extremes reason for
yeah try refreshing maybe but stream is
still going smooth on our end
y'all stop talking no I didn't say we
weren't going to never talk yeah
we're not on stream just to stay like
yeah I'm just we can't we can't just let
the game play and not talk we have to
talk so if you're looking for no talking
sorry
plenty of so this is actually a new
mechanic I would think this wasn't in
for where you can get ammo and weapons
pretty much like fetched by in this case
Dave you know your will robot AI you can
have them assist you know okay I'm
trying to hold on I need to confirm
something here sure that was quite a
that building is gone what did they say
the name of this uh when it was or
island there you go
sus another thing you guys might have
noticed there's skills right oh yeah
yeah there's just like a pulse kill
right here and an interesting thing too
is like it's a lot easier to stealth I
love this check oh here we go
ah all right in the gullet okay I was
right yes this there on the islands
that's from the end of gears 3 yes David
and David in the chat just uh thought
they were at the same time I did yeah
this is the island that used three ended
on oh nice
which is cool that is cool the kind just
revisiting it
yeah this is uh I'm not sure if this is
like a solid 60 I mean this looks real
smooth it does look smooth it does look
pretty like it's supposed to
yes for sure hey I think we can get down
this way there you go some sort of lift
efforts headache pain love that how many
frames does the game run on Xbox so
we're playing on a on an X and it's
running on two smooth 60 here we're not
doing 1080 we're doing 1080 not 4k so I
don't know about 4k right but I'm we
haven't tested it on a launcher Ness I
did to play the game in fourth day it
was running 60 as well okay Wow number
four when they added a 4k support it was
also 60 no good nightmare man
oh nice they've got it looks a little
there you go yeah oh nice
hey yeah thanks Stella
here's doesn't have couch crop anymore
does it no it still does uh yeah I
haven't read it yet it's still hot it
still has split-screen co-op we're
choosing to play single-player I'll be
like debating if we were gonna do close
screen right let's screen we decided to
do single-player cuz I think that's just
maybe the better way to show it first
time through unfortunately we didn't
have a second copy here in the office
right so we couldn't like otherwise we
would have try to do it that way
hmm
so Raymond Raymond Flags is for k30x and
single players 16 multiplayer okay yeah
okay the music settles yeah that makes
sense
I think you'd want multiplayer to be 60
regardless yeah for sure you can you
know I'm loving the color though like
yeah it just pops so nice out some
classic yours the Lord took a right
Risa's leg split the path the party oh
but I'll let you pick it always felt
arbitrary but I still like thinking that
choice me too yeah that's only not again
King wants to know does it launch early
with game pass yes if you have steam
passed Ultimates you get it on Friday
yeah
correct retro I'm not usually as good
with the retro as I am with the what the
Lancer just cuz like just you know
heavier recoil yeah but it's fun yeah
you do
I don't stab someone with it
how do you stop it this way right dr.
wall oh he's too sure all these guys
if you plays other characters yes yes so
I want to say from my knowledge the
majority of the game you're actually
playing is cat right yeah
Kate or Kate I'm sorry I keep some cat I
I do that say keep playing as Kate but I
think here for the intro they're having
plays SJD right you want me to melee so
I will melee
oh that was some gymnastic yeah every
tom is saying specifically if you have a
game pass ultimate you will specifically
get access to it Thursday night at 9:00
p.m.
yeah sure Pacific right Pacific yeah if
you're in Pacific you'll get it Thursday
night is it still four player co-op no
some just three was the only one to have
four player co-op or only had two and
this one has three players sort of co-op
right it's like you can you two people
could play and then the third person can
play is like Jack the AI right so in
this case it'll be Dave
or day the jack yeah which is um
I don't know that's kind of weird I
don't know that's very like that video
game equivalent of getting the the third
party yeah well you gotta play is the
robot right one of the shoe people yes
funny um our very own Matt Padgett
actually I believe if you didn't do it
already
there's definitely a lot to be said
about playing as the AI it feels like it
might be you know a third party thing
but they there's a lot more to it and
it's sure sure hey I don't want to miss
I haven't even tried it but you know for
sure when you hear that you're like no I
love that analogy because I totally know
the feeling of giving like you know your
little sibling or something the third
controller yeah yeah and then your best
around the second letter whatever it's
super funny it's like stuff gamers only
understand right
ten things only gamers oh we got Marcus
and uh Kate Franken demo or full game
this full game we're gonna play back in
an hour of it here so the cool thing
again oh I can mark them hold on to my
liming press all the market
let me mark you should have mark first
uh not him
oh let's mark those guys yeah mark those
dudes blow them up snipe do it you're
gonna do it Kate or what did she just do
it automatically or do you have to you
might have to start shooting okay I'll
just yes maybe this maybe I was shooting
me oh okay nice nice yeah they're doing
their thing yeah when he gets here and
drop a podcast we have a podcast you
know we do our very own uh GameSpot as a
podcast yeah yeah yeah episodes every
Friday
gamespot after dark right yeah yeah
literally recently on there on the most
recent episode weren't you know uh it
was the one before it I was on the one
before it
I had like three big like reviews go out
that was a that was the last one
oh I wasn't on that one yeah we have
Jordan Michael and Peter on because each
reviewed a pretty big game right right
right right
there's like control astral chain
ancestors and yeah pour one out for for
Jordan I've never been good with the
boom shot but all uh dope are dead
too slow yeah dude boom shot and Gnasher
you're bold yeah that's a bold combo
like I got what I needed for the boom
shot i'll go back to my uh well go back
to my regular lands here there we go
there's a third kind of Lancer too and
that's gonna be I hope you can find it
here it's it's uh that's really cool
playing on PC or Xbox one we're playing
on the Xbox one Xbox one two Maddox's we
want podcast with David Onley just like
by yourself yeah just me Fatah girl Mike
Thank You ash oh no no oh
knew it I got too busy
oh thanks Dave a lot of people are
asking if it's open worlds I think that
stuff's kind of already come up right
like the preview stuff well I think so
yeah cuz toriel wise yeah it has yeah
they were kind of talking about that
yeah it's like semi open world yes I
think I open world that trick elements
from what I've read it sounds oh yeah
see here Matt Padgett who actually wrote
our preview on it there you go
what up Matt hey Matt thank you thanks
for joining man the way he was
describing it reminded me of he was
comparing it to Metro Exodus right it's
like this nice middle ground right it's
like yeah it's not like a bread dad or
it's not a like a GTA it's more like
each individual level is just sort of
like more open-ended restore to it
all that guy uh what do we want well
guardians our dear ones
guardians starting I'll say guardians
yeah oh Jesus
oh my god I'm one of these guys they
suck I got a
cuz a B chainsaw anyone yet I have a few
times okay there's another one hey go
and another one oh yeah but I got it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no there's all
these guys like real real really at you
yeah they are they this feels like this
is this is not the slow build-up that
years for was like they expect you to
kind of know what you're doing here sure
there you go so much red so much blood
thanks guys
the Guardians are just like big ol big
oil eh I was just bawling I guess so
oh yeah uh maybe in that hole right
there you can oh yeah yeah wait looks
like they're yeah yeah
uh-oh I'm supposed to send Jack hack
that door yeah rip that door in pinpoint
out but are they sinking cities of the
giant worm yet you see you got him you
got to build up to that that's in the
second act how they gonna play is Marcus
I'd be fun
oh that would be cool I think I think
the remotes were you definitely oh sure
I'm in like the campus oh yeah
Thanks no I think you give a little
acknowledgement it's cute yeah okay I've
got our Gutter clock tags okay well they
just marked it for me that's very nice
of them thank our deeds insulting Dave
it's like well I'm through your [ __ ]
technology oh it's on the other side
okay
Brenden yes it is a busy busy time a lot
of games games
oh no the Guardians down oh geez
we're gonna nah sure man yeah I forgot I
even had a masher BAM
yeah oh that's a very satisfying sound
effect where's Kate Kate is she went in
the other direction
she's going with Marcus right now yeah
it seems like you're playing is JD
during the tutorial and then yeah yeah
after you'll get to but I think the
majority of the game is gonna be playing
as where's the bus case you kind of want
to try shots I get it maybe but I hear
more people there you go nice
there you go
music settles yeah with that little
thank yous that lolled
sting they do every Jewish combat yeah I
missed the the sound whenever you picked
up the [ __ ] tag anyone shoot that window
maybe the this one here or the one front
of me the one in front of you yeah else
I can make it's a glass is broken yeah
so okay we gotta get that door open I
gotta send Dave somewhere again
yeah maybe drop that thing yeah it's
like no I want to take the trash out
with me everywhere I go okay okay so
they said that it's inside you just got
to get Dave in there somehow so there's
gotta be maybe I was trying to think
like oh yeah yeah we got it
nice why are you guys not doing co-op
yes Pokemon go Smitty great name says we
just wanted to do it we thought it would
be a better way to show it off we had
contemplated doing split-screen Brian
figured they'd show off the game better
do single-player but I plan on doing a
lot of co-op with this for sure it's
really refreshing to kind of have that
ability to do sort of couch co-op now
you know it's nice very very nice all
right
commander's office lock zapping
Wow thank you hey control good news we
found the data drive Oh true Kate sorry
it's another boom shop and then what's
this here stem oh that's a some grenades
okay cuz I was like that's a big big ol
crate scare I did throw those grenades
in there
oh no Kate that's fine
like she'll live who go up and grab that
gun the one over there yeah yeah that's
all shiny oh yeah yeah just guns
impossible we go that drops it in the
explodes you can kind of aim when you
yeah oh yeah never got any gears are
they worth it story-wise I like the gear
story I do they're simple but I think
they're effective for what they are
absolutely they're super fun and fours
is not bad subscribe it's also like I
don't know it's it's not as like macho
rah rah rah the whole time as you kind
of think it might be you know the first
one is but definitely like two and three
for sure threes probably the best gears
in my opinion it's it's a good one for
sure yeah obviously I haven't digesting
five now so not counting five and five
yet but I would say three is probably
the best one gross
I love it oh man that's your cover
though oh that's a good point
oh yeah that's definitely cover okay it
seems like maybe oh I gotta go I'm sorry
stuffs happening
[Music]
here we go okay nice it's all yours
control you're in start the launch
sequence first stage options what JD are
you nuts
so let's get it done
the ignition engine one
I've got to learn the stuff yeah good
luck with that
let's get that hatch
trying to shock them like
you guys already giantbomb HQ we don't
have to read their HQ they're literally
on the sink fluorescence my ray their HP
mean go walk 20 feet to their desks and
say hi it's like it's almost like some
area 51 things up we're just right there
yeah I'm gonna go Naruto run yeah uh
pass the breakroom over to their thier
side see what's up to Jeff
yeah see this pole skill is really
convenient yeah especially yeah I
believe that you couldn't can't properly
see you get jacking it back oh yeah how
much wood could a woodchuck chuck
and this is some ballsy stuff these guys
yeah
oh you're still alive nothing wrong it's
all good
got him
nice really
love that oh my gosh
whoa all right it's like a bad situation
yeah this is not how you want to spend
your day after Labor Day
trying to manually open a rug Oh like
canonically it's it's the day after
Labor Day yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly
know what these guys oh my gosh no no
what I'm with dal for Dave yeah
the disrespect
nice I thought that was gonna go worse
for them yes for sure because it's that
whole thing in the in the original III
revealed trailer we're like JD's arms
all like burnt mmm I thought that was
gonna happen to him here for sure that
was gonna be his like hubris was gonna
get his arm Oh Marcus man yeah Marcus
was not happy at all dude papa Phoenix's
upset
JD's about to get a scolding us that's
cute little the Owen Hope was a cog year
[Music]
these cutscenes Rock oh my gosh yeah
looks really good
nice art it's a title
vacation she's not happy
master Jazz's old man Marcus yeah it's
like old man Logan right just as
grizzled veteran
[Music]
James how about I see gin first Oh calm
the storm before you briefer I'm sorry
is this sergeant Phoenix being
diplomatic it's gonna say only yeah you
you have the ground of to live with him
after that stunt we polled it's kind of
insulin stop trying to prove yourself
just do the job dad I took a necessary
rest Sarah means you have no other
option that wasn't necessary and you
know it down yeah I think he's gonna I
think that's how his arms gonna get
furnace he's gonna pull some some
heroics he's gonna try and pull some
heroics he's gonna get himself hurt hey
you know it's just cuz he cares right
Dave's like excuse me folks
yeah how's she anything to say yeah
I'm sorry
the thing is
you throw more alike than either of you
want to admit
family problems man the data is in front
of you demon that's it
I thought the new satellite would
automatically link to the old ones find
them
without regular scheduling from Telecom
and tracking accuracy - great thanks a
lot iris
your vocal sentiment does not match your
words literal meaning yes you are not
actually please stop talking so I still
can't find the other hammer of dawn
satellites on the plus side I
accidentally invented an AI that
understands sarcastic here that data
drive you wanted maybe it'll help find
lost satellites I doubt it but I'll take
a look wait hang on did we do all that
for nothing a little fire but with only
one working satellite up it'll be tough
to control the beam hey Jack
Oh everyone meet the nude I was a new
jack when did I have time to build this
this is what I do I sit here making
stuff you guys don't appreciate an
inevitable break Jack's like no Navi
improve scanning augmented combat and
support modules he's literally one of a
kind
and he's all yours now if you'll excuse
me I have a bazillion forty-year-old
satellites to find there are only 15 de
min come on now Baird's weird robot wife
yeah it's like Sharon from Sponge Bob
Plankton's computer wife follow me
you'll want to equip this new module
ASAP
it'll make Jack combat-ready it'll give
Jack what I've been calling flash it
blinds stuns the enemy
there you go nice so we've got abilities
whoo all right let's do it this is like
check it out here yeah all right so we
got assault support passives and this is
also skill tree let's see a little flash
can stun people mm-hmm the hole the
holes you saw earlier that's the support
one and we got some passives and it
looks like oh you can upgrade them so in
the flat okay yeah so you can get like a
faster recharge the range in your flash
the flash could actually cause damage
that's pretty cool and flash freeze
which is locked and I assume as a lock
for a reason maybe you have to unlock
all three first and then you get like
the last one's probably gonna be like a
big you know look it's big final unlock
supports got more range more duration
and also depicts weapons and ammo
instead of just the enemies that's cool
okay and then let's check these passes
out so you've got revive himself you can
revive down teeth grab names it's pretty
big
yeah yeah yeah that's he well well
that's kind of what happened to me right
with JD and Dave in the beginning that
one time when I was downed and Dave came
over and he'll do killed me that's cool
I like that yeah that's stealth it's
like when he stays cloaked on the
battlefield and stuff and he can carry
like he can stay cloaked when he's
bringing back weapons for you so that's
that's nice and zapper what's this it's
a little lightning shock pieces damage
can hit multiple enemies at once and
then the core okay that can fetch heavy
weapons recharge nobody's faster
interesting alright say there's a bunch
more abilities you can get overtime
right cool
awesome now we're getting a little
tutorial
oh I hate the end the industry -
tutorial yeah we can get a little bit
more grab this yeah
now let's try it again with multiple
targets incoming Jack's got a reroute
power between flat one sees recharge see
metal wait for the recharge on the top
left or the once that goes then I can
okay
he's uh
cool hey guys still got 16 minutes left
yeah that's true hopefully we'll get
through this tutorial quick and some
what I like to run another test now we
know things we're good no Ivan in the
chat thanks Evan all right I got a
return my weapon really can't let me
keep it man I'm sorry I would probably
be able to grab one off I should just
play for an extra hour yeah I gotta go
home man yeah we gotta go I got I got a
long commute editing stuff all day let's
get out of here
skedaddle another cutscene
ooh tomorrow would be like is uh yeah
yeah you're wearing those glasses here
[ __ ] stick series maybe a stick made out
of [ __ ] or or a stick used to stir up
[ __ ] alright [ __ ] off she knows some
unnecessary macho [ __ ] going on okay
they're really setting up like JD just
being rec dude real real cocky yeah cuz
I and I feel like he's gonna get hurt
real bad
all right now they're fast fun times
over
can we go find that component yeah
you'll find that freaking component okay
this is a little that was an optional
thing you could just like interact okay
he's and stuff I see yeah we want to go
to the main objective in the armoury
let's go talk to engineer one hey guys
still have some of the changes they made
some skirts for I'm curious how all the
ability stuffs gonna pan out
yeah I'm pretty excited for them yeah
okay so we got a component so we can we
could potentially upgrade them yeah so
there's like you know something with
okay a health so that's we have one
component and this one color we go in
component there you go done I'm not
gonna interact with that just go I'm
just gonna take away yeah where's the I
gotta wait for them to finish talking
there we go
report the First Minister Jens office is
that door open no I probably got to go
around
guy can't run faster JD come on how much
time left in the stream we're gonna go
for about another 12 minutes gray fox
hello welcome I don't share your
optimism it's the first time anyone's
accused me about them yes well I'll
remind you your wife refused the idea of
bringing the hammer back online I would
have thought you'd respect
Anya's wishes ripp I'm gonna pretend you
didn't say that
for both our sakes Anya would have
wanted you don't get to talk about her
damn if that's what you think I won't
argue that's a sore spot for sharing
with a goddamn fertility program a
program that gave you your son
and by
I honor Anya I loved Anya I don't care
if you believe me when my program was in
its infancy she came to me she
volunteered both times she volunteers
see in First Minister Stroud undergo
treatment do you know how many children
are alive today thanks to her dang she
should be buried here you know with the
old father's the people need her
inspiration your inspiration was my wife
first minister lieutenant Phoenix is one
man so I was like some backs we never
learned before what happened to Anya
right I guess she died as part of like
that fertility program it sounded for
sure for sure and definitely almost like
a martyr type thing - she writes you can
kind of volunteered for the greater good
they're kind of implying when Damon
Baird superseded me explain how
launching a hammer of dawn satellite
she's mad I thought Marcus was supposed
to like kind of water it down a bit
right yeah dawn has taken more cog lives
than most of the armies we've opposed
your father knows this as well as anyone
it's not the weapons I don't trust First
Minister it's the people who use them
the hammer of dawn will not be brought
back online
oh ah that'll be a report on the
evacuation of settlement to settlement
to is being evacuated why there's been
activity in the nearby burial site
chief carmine report carmine not that
carmine will a carmine yeah a car bomb
mobilized in the crisper man like we'll
take a minute yeah and the second one
died and the third one didn't you the
sick cleat and that might be the third
one at Minot
here we go we're gonna get a little more
action for guests yeah we had some good
action in the beginning surprisingly it
kind of threw us in I appreciate that
and they're like alright now we're gonna
we're gonna hit you with the curveball
of all that exposition okay Clayton
carmine was the carmine from three okay
so that might still be Clayton could be
a different car - because she said chief
carmine here some curious yeah that
might be the same carmine from three
Oh bull train a little weird intro for
him
yeah just like oh no setup opens the
word closes door that's probably the
only time you see him then it just Jets
out
Oh
I love this little like set-pieces
yeah I'm surprised how much they're
making us play as JD yeah for sure
before we kids like they very much
pitched
oh they got grenades on them oh this is
a new gun the Talon Allen auto pistol
nice kiddies your leg okay he's like
just stuck in this little position here
oh he's getting like a wreck
all right oh here we go oh that's fun oh
hey buddies no she's bad yeah oh love it
I always look very differently fire and
like the old campaigns the Phoenix would
just yell like down in front no he's so
like there's like any time you did an
inactive reload they'll just yell like
no yeah oh hell yeah good nuts I like
reading that stuff nah stream yeah
exactly
but I do need a component there we go
let's go
you know enforcer
I usually enforcer you I think it's
better in this one I care for he didn't
like it in the yeah he Sharia right I
think it still kind of is um but I had
never used them for after the Rihanna
thing I think that was like eight gears
work for thing oh yeah that's that's a
Forbes Pacific and it was serve like I'm
one of the new weapons is a plus a store
Mac like a broom act but wouldn't stop
the other way
gray fox yes qs5 has full coop story
mode two people and then the third
person can play as like your your bot
jack if you want which I'm curious how
that's actually gonna play out yeah and
I ain't it's you know split screen
online local all that good stuff
yep what's your favorite like gears line
gears line yeah like just like a thing
they've said from like I feel like I
always remember what they saying here's
because it's just so ridiculous it's
hard for me to say I can't like oh
actually yeah I love Dom rip Dom but in
like the earlier ones there's this
moment when actually no sorry Baird
Baird and cooler in the sewers thank you
everyone
they have to go in the sewers and you
and Dom are up on the top floor and you
finally see them you're like oh what's
up boys and they're just like all
covered and like [ __ ] yeah and finally
at some point Baird goes hey there's
room for one more it's a party down here
I always loved their sinking cities with
a giant from - that that's like that's
good and then it's it's not a like it's
a line but it's like an easter egg
oh there's a part in to where you can
blow up a pillar okay you find like a
purple toaster and you like can do it
and then like it smokes and smokes and
then there's like burnt toast pops up
and Marcus just yells who wants toast oh
yeah I like mine extra crispy yeah and
it's one of the funniest Easter eggs I
love it
oh it's really good but yeah I just
always find a funny one Jared's
and this year and as some muscles good
maybe I'll kill this guy oh never mind
all right
she's cool
can we play as her yeah damn all right
Lizzie
all right she's my new favorite
character now for sure been since I
heard giant worms
howdy I like other people in the in the
chat saying their favorite lines when
you shot your partner by accident Markus
will go you're blocking my shot yeah
your bloody son said here comes the coal
train oh yeah well how about don't worry
I got the code oh and I'll remove that
one yeah what's that one
there we go got a long shot good sniper
yeah I love the long shot yeah your
snipers always hit real hard yeah they
do and just a sound effect you know oh
yeah it's gonna chainsaw but I forgot
you get staggered at the stay yeah yeah
gotta gotta play it yeah maybe I could
flash well I think Marcus is gonna die
in this game someone's asking I don't
think so
I don't think so I don't think they're
gonna I don't think they're gonna kill
Marcus not in this one but kind of like
for really like made you think they were
gonna kill him they were really like
trying to hammer in like oh you might
die like who knows and then he doesn't
and I was like ah cool this game
probably is gonna have so many other
emotional points going on that it
doesn't there's gonna be a lot of highs
and lows sure it doesn't feel like it
needs necessarily needs to happen for
story purposes right but I could be
wrong may kill him but I don't think so
it's awesome my theories now all right
we're actually out of time here so maybe
we want to clear up this encounter yeah
after this and then call it sounds good
to me
oh this is a good one someone says in
Gears 3 when you find a cardboard cutout
of coal at a supermarket and he goes the
coal train runs on whole grain baby I I
don't remember that that is gold yeah
that's a real that's a real that's a
real good one I remember quote now a lot
after that game that's such a good like
play on like you know football stars on
like Wheaties boxes and stuff like yeah
all the stuff with the coal train and
three with the like thrash ball
it's like real good that's so good Oh
big boy
[Music]
just one laughs that guy there get him
just wants to poke his head streets
clear GG alright let's watch this
cutscene with with oh you what you want
to I want to see more Lizzy before we
where you cut this out here oh boy we
thought we were gonna hope nevermind oh
gosh one more encounter these guys
they're gnarly oh do you match that
button yeah you want to get the belly
yeah okay so there you go when you use
the flash David heck yeah alright am I
gonna get do we get it's harder yeah
there we got Ruger Polizzi
Lizzy come on Lizzy
yeah they need you Bob don't just gonna
send this off you can get there through
the park
all right rip not not enough Lizzy Ben
yeah well I think that intro of Lizzy
was cool though yeah Renae to the face
and just like totally that was awesome
well I think that's a good luck we've
been playing for just a slight bit over
now an hour here so yeah we got to see
that that intro gonna go rescue Carmen
he's apparently still in the game nice
cool yeah we got some really cool
cutscenes yeah great I'm shocked how
much you're still playing JD in the
intro yeah yeah that's like three full
chapters you know so far yeah I wonder
if like maybe the first full act is just
JD and they're kind of maybe kind of
building it up I heard I heard this is a
longer Gears campaign compared to yeah
yeah it's definitely a longer Gears
campaign the game itself is a lot bigger
than previous games too and you know
like I mentioned early in the beginning
of the stream we're gonna have so much
coverage on the video side of things
about how big gear 5 will be the
different type of characters hey you
gotta see a lot yeah so you're gonna
you're gonna be able to kind of cool
yeah with us great Fox for asking about
review I'm not sure allowed to say
exactly when right I don't think we're
allowed to exactly win but I can say
very soon yeah very soon
I've seen the games out Friday for
everyone so very soon I know that we're
probably gonna have an initial review
and then I believe we might be waiting a
little bit for a full review for
multiplayer accessions I don't yeah but
at the very least there will be an
initial review of campaign yeah that
absolutely very soon
yeah for sure I mean yeah you just gotta
wait for those servers to come live
right exactly and they can fully test
that out and make sure all that's
working absolutely so yeah so thank you
guys for joining us for the first hour
of Gears 5 it looks good so far
yeah that a lot of fun I'm excited for
it yeah totally yeah cool man yeah I
will thanks for joining us
we'll see you guys tomorrow
at the usual eleven o'clock a m--
pacific time for our usual stream not
sure we're streaming I don't know I
think but I think purchase got something
and I just got something Chris got Sun
in store for you guys oh yeah she check
that out and then I know that I'll
definitely be back on Friday
yeah community Fridays is that just been
a couple weeks since we did one cuz I
was at PAX last week right right Ben was
off and stuff but we're gonna be playing
Monster Hunter world ice-born yeah yeah
she comes out on Friday yo we're
bringing back the Monster Hunter for
those who remember me and been doing
that season for that a lot of good stuff
there thanks for joining us guys and we
will see you later later guys